what in the hell has a drag queen ever  done  to make you have so much respect for  them and admire them so much  other than put on makeup and and jump on  the floor and ride around and do sexual  things on stage  i have absolutely no idea  why  you would want that to influence your  child  would you want a stripper or a porn star  to influence your child  it makes no sense at all  a drag queen performs in a nightclub for  adults there is a lot of filth that goes  on a lot of sexual stuff that goes on we  have already had a reputation of being  pedophiles and being perverts and  deviants we don't need you to bring your  children around so you keep your kids at  home or take them to disneyland or take  them to chuck e cheese  preach preach drag queen you're telling  it like it is i love that line take him  to chuck e cheese what's wrong with you  people